hi this is cynthia thomas i'm a
networking specialist at google cloud
welcome back to what's new in networking
today we'll focus on edge and security
related launches
stay tuned
first let's talk about cloud armor
manage protection plus
this is a service that packages ddos
protection
cloud armor wav functionality and future
protection capabilities
into an enterprise friendly subscription
managed protection aims to simplify
cloud armor deployments
reduce management overhead and minimize
financial risk
cloud armor managed protection plus
subscribers
will also have access to additional
value-add services
including adaptive protection named ip
lists
and other future services well the
future is now
and we have some exciting additions to
cloud armor manage protection plus
introducing ddos response and bill
protection services
with ddos response customers can get
help with
analyzing and mitigating ongoing ddos
attacks
customers with premium support have the
opportunity to engage
ddos response services and get access
to sre and engineering teams
that are responsible for dos protection
for all of google
customers who suffered from a ddos
attack
may see an increase in their
infrastructure bill with bill protection
on the covered resources you can now
open a claim with billing support
and receive credits for the amount of
the spike
provided that the attack was
sufficiently large
now on to more security launches
until now you couldn't deploy firewall
rules
at an organization or folder level now
you can with
hierarchical firewall policies with
hierarchical firewall
policies security admins can define and
enforce
firewall rules at the organization and
folder levels
in the gcp resource hierarchy
firewall policies make rules management
easier
policies contain multiple firewall rules
that are attachable
to an organization or folder
hierarchical firewalls enable automatic
protection
for new projects and networks
it also allows flexible firewall
configurations
required for complex cloud environments
next is a super exciting feature that
just went ga
secure data exchange for vpc service
controls
vpc service controls is a key
differentiator for gcp
and works to prevent data exfiltration
with secure data exchange you now have
more
fine gain controls on the data exchanged
down to the method and organization
level
for example you can enable your partners
to have read-only access
to a gcs bucket from a different
organization
finally we're excited to announce the
general availability
of request coalescing often known as
collapsing
for cloud cdn request coalescing
collapses multiple user-driven cash fill
requests
for the same cash key into a single
origin request
per edge node we have already been
applying this behavior
on chunk requests since last year but
now this is the default for all request
types
request coalescing is now the default
behavior
for all new and existing cloud cdn
customers
benefiting from a reduced load on the
origin
and that's what's new in networking for
edge and security
let us know your thoughts on these new
features in the comments below
check out the links for more info on how
to use them
and join us next time to learn more
about what's new in networking